I don't know if in do unboxing videos in
my channel partly this is a function of
not having the time to do that sort of
thing but also I think that quite a few
of the things I unpacked might not be
all that interesting to my viewers but I
have something this time that I'm going
to do that with but first a little bit
of backstory about why it's particularly
important
so you see here I'm in my studio and the
truck Ward is right across from me the
truck Ward where you see me doing so
many of my videos and we didn't really
pay close enough attention or rather I
didn't
- how much truck was left and there's
not an awful lot so in addition to the
stuff that I'll show you in a second
this is the supply that I have on hand
then there's also three more pieces of
truck in this and I thought we had more
left or you know left over from other
purchases but no that's it and now that
we're in this big quarantine there were
some worries about getting some some
truck sometimes I can scavenge some from
classrooms or things like that so we we
decided to order some and we put in a
shopping order and and you know right
now we're in self quarantine so we had a
shopper
go and get us a truck and unfortunately
we weren't really really specific about
the kind of truck that we needed a lot
of people don't know that there's
different kinds of chalk right a
classroom chalk or chalkboard chalk and
so we got this really basic Crayola
chalk and you can actually when you
listen to how it rings it has a
different sound to it because it's not
quite the same as the other truck this
piece of truck right here this is really
solid this is very light very Airy and
when they write on the chalkboard they
produce different you know you might say
effects this wears down very quick
squeaks and it's harder to erase
incidentally but it also is not very
durable it'll snap this is real chalk
real you know professor real up at the
chalkboard kind of truck so you don't
want to get the two of them mixed up I'm
gonna put this back in here this will be
my slumming truck if worse ever comes to
worse and I'm still shooting stuff and
I'm out of truck altogether I'll use
this stuff but otherwise it's going into
the junk drawer and sticking there so on
to the package what we've got here we
ordered some of this you know better
truck from Amazon and I haven't opened
it up let's see if we actually got what
we were supposed to have came a couple
days ago Oh
shoe shop with Amazon it's a package
inside a package it's heavy that's
promising right if that's the kind of
truck we like isn't it so let's take a
look again all right
more packaging - Oh more packaging
inside that surprise surprise but this
is also a good sign
see how it's kind of dusty there that's
the real stuff so what do we have here
Crayola quality low dust chalkboards
truck bright white for easy visibility
makes clean smooth lines and erases
easily that there we go it's the anti
dust truck and this stuff you hear that
you hear all different that sound is
from what the other truck was like let
me get that other truck out for a second
hear that sound two very different kinds
of compounds here made of the same stuff
ultimately but this is about twice as
dense so what do we have here we have
one
you three feel like I'm the count on
Sesame Street for five and six
so this supply is going to carry me
through for a long long time we've got
more than enough chalk here for me to
shoot probably another thousand videos
at this point in time I've got you know
like seventeen hundred in the channel so
pretty cool you know this is exactly
what I needed
and now I am set you can take well
there's a little some of these they're
broken up a little bit but that's okay
not that big of a deal it's all gonna
get broken anyway because what do I do I
take these these long pieces and I snap
them in two so that it's easier for me
to write with so now I've got plenty of
truck for my endeavors and I won't be
running out anytime soon now it's just
not going to run out of chalkboard
anytime soon either this is a great
investment that we made years ago I
could probably get rid of the little
tiny fragments that I've been making do
with some of you may have seen me using
these from time to time these little
what do you call nubs chalk nubs you
know they're almost like little balls
here aren't they so that is the
unpackaging very successful look at all
this wonderful track that I've got so
now I don't have any excuses for not
getting a lot of video work done hope
that you'll tune in and you know if you
enjoyed this I might do some other
unpackaging things when things arrive
that could be of some interest to all of
you viewers
you